مشهد مروع، يبحثون عن
أشلاء من
أحبائهم، الانفجار قوي جدًا
[موسيقى] ولم
يترك سوى القليل من ضحاياه
وراءهم كان هناك رجل عجوز حيث هذا
الكرسي المتحرك يقول الرجل حاولنا
التقاط جثته كانت الجثث هنا
كلها
مشوهة  هي أراضي
مستشفى AA حيث تم تخييم عدد لا يحصى من الأبرياء
هنا على يقين من أنه كان
آمنًا في الليل، وقد تمزق الملجأ
بسبب انفجار قوي،
وتحول مكان الشفاء إلى مكان مذبحة
قتل فيها المئات أو كانوا يأملون في
إنقاذ الإدانة والاتهام  جاء
التدفق قبل أن يتم
إحصاء القتلى، ونفت إسرائيل مسؤوليتها
واتهمت جماعة فلسطينية مسلحة،
وأضافت أن عدم وجود أضرار هيكلية
استبعد احتمال شن
غارة جوية، وأصدر الجيش الإسرائيلي مقطعًا صوتيًا يُزعم أنه
أسر اثنين من نشطاء حماس
يناقشان إطلاق
صاروخ من حركة الجهاد الإسلامي بشكل خاطئ على  تشير
معلومات استخباراتية لمستشفى غزة من مصادر قليلة
بين أيدينا إلى أن
حركة الجهاد الإسلامي هي المسؤولة عن
إطلاق الصاروخ الفاشل الذي أدى إلى إخفاء
المستشفى في غزة، لكن
المسؤولين الفلسطينيين والقادة العرب رفضوا
نفي إسرائيل واتهموا جيشها
باستهداف المنشأة الطبية عمداً.
لا أستطيع التحقق من سبب
الانفجار.
أثار الغضب في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
مظاهرات في العديد من
الدول العربية مع تزايد المخاوف من نشوب صراع أوسع نطاقا. عند
وصول الرئيس بايدن إلى إسرائيل خلال
هذه اللحظة الفاصلة التي كان
من المقرر أن
يجتمع فيها كل من الأردن والسلطة الفلسطينية قبل وصوله، شعرت
بحزن عميق و  غاضب من أه
الانفجار الذي وقع في المستشفى في غزة
أمس وبناء على ما رأيته
يبدو كما لو أنه تم من قبل
الفريق الآخر وليس أنت بعد
ساعات من الهجوم ومحاطة
بالقتلى وزارة الصحة في غزة ألقت باللوم على
إسرائيل وقالت  تعرضت المنشأة للقصف بصواريخ جيش
الدفاع الإسرائيلي قبل أيام، حيث
كان نظام المستشفيات في غزة على حافة الهاوية
حتى قبل هذا الهجوم.
الأزمة الإنسانية تخرج الآن عن نطاق السيطرة،
وتقول جماعات حقوق الإنسان إن حوالي مليوني شخص
نصفهم من الأطفال محاصرون في
منطقة حرب حضرية  الحصار الكامل الذي فرضته
إسرائيل بعد هجوم إرهابي لحماس أدى إلى مقتل
1400 شخص، أغلق الحدود
وقطع الغذاء والمياه والوقود،
وسيكون هناك وقت لإجراء
تحقيقات وربما إجابات واضحة،
لكن هذا لا يفعل الكثير بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يعانون
والحداد في غزة
الآن